Once it clicks that you can make anything you want from scratch,
yes, including Snickers,
you'll never go back to buying the ultra processed junk again.
I started by making my new got
first by whipping egg white until stiff peaks formed,
then cooking the unrefined
natural sugars into a thick caramel at 200 2 degrees Fahrenheit.
I slowly drizzled this hot syrup into the whipped egg white,
but quickly moved it to a bowl with a hand mixer,
which worked much better. This was like marshmallow fluff,
it was so smooth and satiny.
I poured the fluff into a butter dish,
although I would use Parchment paper next time,
then move that to the fridge to firm up for a few hours.
Then I got to making the caramel filling with butter,
coconut sugar, water and cream.
I chopped up some almonds and added those into the thick caramel
and then spread this on top of my chilled newgot.
While that firmed up in the fridge,
I made my dark chocolate. A very quick process.
Lastly, I cut the newgot and caramel nut filling into small pieces,
dipped each piece in the chocolate,
then placed in the fridge to firm up for a few minutes.
Afterwards,
I dunked each Snickers again for an extra thick double dunked candy.
I can't tell you how good these were.
They're actually drool worthy
and if I keep making them,
I'll get better at the shape.
I can confidently say I feel good About feeding my kids a Snickers bar.
As long as it's homemade with real ingredients.